have you ever wondered what it would be
like to study quantum physics at a
prestigious uni in a few seconds I will
unbox a quantum physics exam from MIT
but first I wanted to show you that I've
got a new kitten
his name is ketchup the exam our show is
publicly available on the MIT
OpenCourseWare site the link will be
down in the description and it's from
the course quantum physics 1 which is an
undergraduate course the website also
has some lecture notes and even an
online version of the course which you
can take which would help you learn the
material that's involved here but for
now let's just have a look at what the
exam involves it will seem difficult for
anyone who hasn't taken this exact
course so don't let it discourage you
and take it with a bit of a grain of
salt if you're just looking at this from
the outside here's the exam here there
are six questions and we've got three
hours to do it
first let's have a little look at the
formula sheet which comes with the exam
have a bit of everything on here Fourier
transforms Delta functions things about
the Schrodinger equation and operators
as well as some integrals a solution of
the Schrodinger equation for an infinite
square well and over here maybe some
things for more specific questions we
have the raising and lowering operators
where things to do with normalization
and angular momentum we won't use all of
these things during the exam this is
kind of just the set of all possible
things which we might need to remember
here opening up the exam our first
question has to do with eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions for this strange-looking
potential that we have here so as a bit
of context in quantum physics you have
something called a wave function which
contains all the measurable information
about a system if you operate something
called the Hamiltonian which has to do
with total energy on the wave function
we get the Schrodinger equation and
solutions for the time independent
Schrodinger equation only exists for
certain values of energy and these
energy values are called eigen values
these eigen values have associated eigen
functions and this question is asking us
various properties about these when we
have this particular like potential
energy going on we have something about
the double slit experiment where we get
this pattern on the wall we're asked to
work out something about the set up
another question here about wave
functions and potentials so it's saying
if we have this strange-looking
potential shape here what is our wave
function going to look like and they've
drawn this picture but there's something
wrong with this picture and the question
is asking us to work out why this fails
to be a correct representation this page
here is similar again it's about
boundary conditions this time and still
about eigenstates notice that we're
still on question one we're just up to G
and H right here another similar one
here except this time we're being asked
to draw the probability density or
essentially the wave function squared
and then a question asking us how
solutions would be different for bosons
fermions or distinguishable particles
that's finally the end of question 1 and
question 2 here starts off with actually
a bit of condensed matter physics so
we're asked about the link between the
letter spacing and diamond and the band
gap as the letter spacing is decreasing
the atoms are closer together and the
binding force between the valence
electrons and the parent atoms will
increase for this we would expect the
band gap to go up because the band gap
is representing the amount of energy
that needs to be given to these valence
electrons to make them become conduction
electrons another question here about
diamond and it's asking what is the
minimum wavelength at which a diamond in
a jewelry store is opaque on to question
3 and we're being asked to consider a
mass m and 2d confined to a square box
by an infinite potential and then there
is no potential inside the box and we
asked several questions about it this is
probably somewhat standard for questions
about quantum physics things like being
asked about the degeneracy of states
and quantum physics states are
degenerate if they give the same value
of energy upon measurement Christian
four is all about the hydrogen atom we
have some questions here about
normalization of the wavefunction how
the wavefunction will evolve with time
and then a few problems about
expectation value the expectation value
is the expected value of the result of a
measurement of an experiment it's an
average of all the possible outcomes of
the experiment weighted by their
likelihood so it's a bit of Statistics
and there's a few questions here about
it expectation value is denoted by these
brackets here some more questions about
making a measurement in terms of wave
functions and then question five we're
given a potential here we're told
suppose the potential has precisely two
bound States sketch the corresponding
wave functions how does the higher
energy bound state look when its energy
is close to zero do another sketch of
that so that if drawing and then
answering more questions about that
little systems here we have a wave that
is being reflected so here we're asked
to calculate the reflection coefficient
which will involve finding out C and D
from this equation here this is a
general solution to the schrodinger when
we solve it using various boundary
conditions that we know of on to our
final question number six and it's about
the harmonic oscillator here we can see
that we're using the letter operators
these operators can raise or lower the
eigenvalue of another operator so in
terms of energy they could go from one
energy level to the next and I think
they will be a useful tool in answering
some of these questions here we're being
asked to find the allowed energies for a
particle in a particular harmonic
oscillator potential we're using our
ladder operators here and some relations
between them to show a couple of
statements and a few more over here and
then we're on to our last question
verify that these here are
eigenfunctions of this and find their
eigen
so it looks like to do well in this exam
you need to know your Schrodinger
equation and solving it very well as
well as dealing with eigenvalues and
eigenfunctions these are kind of
abstract terms but they will be
introduced to you in any first course on
quantum mechanics I would say this exam
was quite tricky I don't think I would
pass just from my memory of what I did
in my own quantum mechanics courses you
really need to be back in the practice
of solving problems like this and
remembering how all the details work
together a lot of people have sort of a
hobby interest in quantum mechanics but
this would be quite a hard exam if you
haven't done some more of the rigorous
proofs or examples that you would find
in a textbook so I would say that
something like the Griffiths quantum
mechanics textbook would be good level
for some of the stuff and also just
checking out you know the lecture notes
and examples on the MIT course itself we
saw a lot of working with potentials
here and just you know being able to
adapt our knowledge of potentials to
work with some you know more unusual
shapes I hope that was a little bit of
insight for you into the world of what
it's like to study this somewhere like
MIT thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]